what are some of the biggest challenges
you faced as a filmmaker starting your
own production company
um let's see starting my own production
company well
I'll go back to this book of Manning
project because that was my first big
really big project I had working on and
so we did this film
and I went and showed it to Archie and
Olivia Manning and as I'm showing it to
him Archie Manning's like taking down
these notes and I'm thinking like
I thought the movie was pretty good you
know and then the movie ended and Olivia
was like Wow Rory like you that was a
wonderful you did a wonderful job in
Archer's like yeah you did good core it
was good and then she's like what were
you writing he's like I was writing down
all the parts I liked so he I was
thinking like we're good
so
um it comes time to hire the narrator
for the project and it's going to be
John Goodman the actor John Goodman
now I had never hired a narrator before
on my own I've worked with narrators but
never through my production company so
apparently uh at the time at least ESPN
was a non-sag company with sag and
there's some gray area when it comes to
narrators whether that should be a part
of sag or not is that acting is it not
you know should it be included I don't
know so
uh
this was a this was over 10 years ago so
I could tell the story I guess
um
I did something wrong apparently I
contacted sag I did something and but
when I say I did something wrong I mean
like I messed up by like 10 minutes
because then I called the someone from
ESPN call and they say as long as you
didn't do this you're fine and I had
done exactly that 10 minutes earlier
so uh John Goodman is supposed to
narrate in New Orleans
and I go to the narration
and it's the day that morning actually
it was that morning I'm on a call with
lawyers from not just ESPN but from
Disney
so it went from John Goodman's not going
to narrate today to John Goodman's not
going to narrate period to maybe we
should pull this film like just pull it
like it was finished
to maybe we should pull everything
Rory's ever done for us like all in the
course of one phone call so I was like
oh my God and
um
I actually got sick to my stomach I I
bought a beignet at the airport took a
bite of it and threw it up in the trash
can that's how worried I was that I had
basically screwed my career up because
ESPN was my main client at the time and
they're kind of saying I can't work for
them again because I made this mistake
that apparently had a domino effect so
uh I I went and called sag myself when I
landed and I spoke to this guy
who was very nonchalant about uh and not
and kind of cavalier kind of like well
I'm gonna put out a memo saying that
ESPN is a non-sag friendly company
and I'm like wait what like why would
you do that and he was telling me and I
said look
I just kind of threw myself at his Mercy
I said like I act up okay that's what I
told him I effed up it's my fault I'm
inexperienced
please can you is there anything you can
do show Mercy whatever and then
he said well I'll think about it and
I'll decide tomorrow morning well in the
meanwhile I called John Goodman's
manager and I said like is there
anything he can do
he said I'll talk to John about it so I
had this night of just not knowing
what's going to happen
it's trying to come to realization that
you know this is it I might have to go
beg for my job back somewhere at NASCAR
and uh the next day my lawyer called me
he's like hey I don't know what happened
or what you did but sag is gonna make an
allowance on this project they're gonna
make an allowance and I was like really
oh wow and I had to pay I think John
Goodman an extra 25 Grand of like
residuals or something at that point I
would have like given up like a finger I
mean I was just so relieved and then I
saw when I saw John Goodman the next
week at the narration like he walked in
I never met this guy before he walked in
I hugged him I was just so happy that he
oh and he I remember oh you know he's
like he could have like punched me but
he was very friendly and then I was like
oh you know thank you for for calling
there he's like oh yeah you know they
mean well whatever and then I mentioned
to him
about like oh you know and I somehow
about the extra 25 Grand he's like I'm
getting paid for this like he didn't
even know he was getting paid so
um I don't know if he still has the same
management but that it worked out it was
one of those things where it really
looked like I was riding the line of
just completely screwing up everything
but he narrated it the film came out
went really well got to do more films
after that but I was this close so
and something that I see that's sort of
a pattern in some of the stories that
I've heard either today or in previous
interviews is um how this this roller
coaster ride I think you've talked about
like not freaking out which is a natural
human response anybody would but that
this is maybe part of like your world
can be devastated one day but you don't
know in a week from now it may all work
itself out yeah is that something you've
become more comfortable with
I think that's life I mean I think
that's you know you think about
somebody breaks your heart or you break
up with you think your world's ended and
then maybe you meet the person in your
dreams a year later or something but
you know it's not the end of the world
when these things happen it's not like
you try to put things in perspective
that you know you can get another job
and things can come around and I think
that's a big big part of being a
filmmaker is resilience and and being in
production like there's a reason why
it's your channel is called film courage
I go back to that word courage a lot you
have to have some
you have to have that I don't think you
can make it without having courage it
doesn't mean you're not afraid it means
you can be afraid but
you know you're willing to just keep
moving forward you know and uh
deal with adversity and my my favorite
movie is Rocky my favorite movie of all
time and not just because of the story
and every but also from
the telling of what Sylvester Stallone
had to go through to get the movie made
he had to basically bet on himself he
took he took a huge risk where he turned
down all this money to just be the
writer of it and have someone else play
him he said no I want to play him and I
think
you usually hear about it after the fact
and everyone's like oh of course like
who else would play Rocky but Sylvester
Stallone but in the moment people are
telling you you know
you're an idiot or you know you've got
to have that that feeling and and maybe
I I don't mean to go off topic too much
but in my my feature movie I've had
people tell me I had a lawyer tell me I
might as well take money and flush it
down the toilet it's what he said about
making a movie and then I had my agent
my actual agent sorry agent um that
Christopher Nolan can't get a movie in
theaters what makes you think you can do
this and so
you just have to have that mentality of
you know what F you I'm doing it so
um and that kind of belief in yourself
and and perseverance that through
because there's going to be crappy times
and crappy things are going to happen to
you and people are going to say mean
things and things are going to be unfair
and things are not gonna work out that
you know as long as the sun rises the
next day and you're here to see it
there's hope
does the word no invigorate you
it definitely doesn't invigorate me I'd
rather hear yes but you know someone did
say you can hear it's a cliche you can
hear a thousand no's you just need one
yes so it depends what it's coming from
but I mean I'd much rather hear yes I
mean no is
still can be debilitating
um
but
I just think people do respond to
Passion
and hopefully sincerity people can kind
of tell are you walking the walk are you
just talking the talk you know are you
really ready to like get in the trenches
and get to it so
um so hopefully they see that and maybe
again it's just no for now uh maybe just
know for now try to look at it that way